vous êtes en cinquième et vous avez un
don incroyable pour le calcul et
n'importe quoi on va perdre déjà très
rapidement un petit test
donnez moi tous très facile des chiffres
très facile comme ça l'un après l'autre
à 10 17 fois le non dit non à cuba 10
chf quoi vous et à la recherche
non mais c'est pas lui tue pas 8 x 8
[Applaudissements]
allez oui oui oui oui tweet tweet 36,44
lewis hamilton
ban de 90 c'est un truc de malade alors
j'aimerais qu'on fasse un petit jeu les
chirico défini près de moi venez là on
voit qu'on fasse un petit jeu avec tout
le monde
chaque chroniqueur chez vous allez me
redonner cette fois ci un nombre entre
10 et 99 et je vais rajouter les invités
également d'accord même kelly
c'est bon c'est qu'on va bien chacun
votre tour vous allez me le donner moi
je vais le noter sur une calculatrice et
on va voir si vous êtes plus rapide que
la calculette d'accord attention c'est
parti on y va jean-michel 73 53 21 44 70
de minutes aux 38 oui 98 oui van den
oui 18 oui kelly 25 combien 474 462
[Musique]
alors ça c'est rien
allez c'est bon c'est pas la peine de
mettre la musique tout ça c'est les
cacahuètes c'est l'apéritif chez mais
maintenant on va faire le défi pour
gagner la trottinette électrique et la
console de jeu attendez vous allez faire
ensemble
j'ai quelque chose oui qui tient quand
même c'est que c'est bizarre parce que
tant qu'une calculatrice est normal que
tu arrives pas mais si tu le faisais mes
que un crayon à papier comme dans
[Applaudissements]
depuis avec jupe à stéphane bern
mais je vous le dis faites gaffe de
réputation de faire des sandwiches va
dormir là on le fait en gros je crois
que s'il y aura les chroniqueurs qui
pourrait le faire aussi perdre de temps
pour après une permission alors
attention c'est parti si vous nous
rejoignez je vais mettre cinq chiffres
multipliés par cinq autres chiffres on
aura une minute trente
d'accord pour le foyer ainsi fait vous
le faites tout lui dire oui en fait
enfin on se concerte d'accord attention
tu voudrais pas de bruit oui pas de
bruit voilà celui qui fait un bruit je
le sors et je l'amène chez la
conseillère faisait partie de ces
troubles
on peut avoir un crayon qui narges
sachets arturia ça je me suis moi
tunisien symphonie merci je change de
feuilles car je la garde et anarchy
meurt à chaque fois elle servira ce
mouchoir à gilles verdez consonne
voyelle
on a dit du calme la frappe de leurs
maux attention au fond de la classe
alors qu'est l'écriture de bouffon
c'est la dernière série d'écriture
d'autistes way l'un des créatures
d'authie l'écriture d'autisme et vous
reconnaîtrez ma signature sur le
licenciement métropole tableau la
poussée vous aussi vous plaît attention
les petits traits faire un break 30
j'avais une minute trente yacine et
amine ben stiller je voulais sans
attention c'est parti
une mule 30 tu veux faire de mon côté
mois allez-y comme auxerre l'armée cher
à la banque ait un tea party
c'est énorme
c'est tout
4,7 en paix
ce
monsieur bouchard une lettre va mieux
j'avais pirates 703 7
il nous reste onze oui et une pression
là
2004 et puissant
j'ai jamais eu un plateau aussi talbot
irène frachon
chiche
on laisse 15 secondes on laisse 15
secondes en plus un tour là quand même
15 c'est bon c'est bon
d'abord attention on va le faire
ensemble
si vous avez bon vous repartirez avec un
vélo une trottinette électrique
électrique
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'ai voulu je voulais envoyer de cette
protéine est comme ça et criques et et
toi il se console de jeux attention il
faut en moyenne 6 à 7 minutes pour
madame même plus à moi je vous dis moi
je mets 25 minutes pour le faire alors
attention le 8 c'est bon leucate bon
c'est bon le 6 c'est bon le 3 c'est bon
le 7 c'est bon le 7 c'est encore bon le
8 c'est bon et vous terminez par koala à
3 333 g13 bon voilà
[Applaudissements]
à bonne échelle
et former la nuit
[Applaudissements]
à toi
ras bord et à sydney il ya un truc
énorme mais c'est quand même dans le
rail occupez vous des porsche espère
voir la console c'est une ps4
on a bâti une belle idée
[Applaudissements]